what's up Lee you got the lighter
tonight I always got a lighter I love
lighting [__] on fire all right let's do
it what's happening you bad
[__] it's Tuesday the 30th of
January the checkin is brought to you by
my people on it listen you want to start
the year off on a good foot start it off
healthy with a little Alpha Brain and
get that [__] coconut on fire go to
hit.com right now go through see what
they have what works for you the shroom
Tech listen tremendous it don't work on
me no more because my lungs are shot the
bong hits have destroyed it but the
[__] Alpha Brain is still kicking
that's why I'm kicking today I'm on my
[__] cycle I got another two weeks
left and then I'll be reciting [__]
poetry and nii and whatever you [__]
guys bought but anyway go to honor.com
press in code coco or Joey and get 10%
off your first daughter all right and
now without further Ado welcome to the
checkin turn off your TVs run for your
lives it's over they didn't put you on
this planet just to give up if Uncle
Joey could do it I could rule the world
I you got to be thinking welcome back to
[Laughter]
show
oh [__] it's almost [__] February guy
I know can you believe it [__] I woke up
this morning like January 29th
godamn it's almost beautiful [__] day
to be alive was cloudy cold
windy but that's the way it's been the
last couple [__] days Sunday was just
God awful really but who gives a [__] we
still got to get up and be [__] [__]
slaves you know what I'm saying it don't
[__] matter you still got to get up
and get whipped and [__]
hit but a beautiful live fellas great
week you know I heard you in [__] uh
Vancouver Washington up
there Canada yeah yeah it was
[__] it was
awesome so they sell cocaine in stores
dude they sell everything in like and I
didn't get to go because apparently I
wasn't in Vancouver but Josh went they
had a story like the same way you look
at a
dispensary it's just the one he went to
was mushrooms but they sell everything
there they sell heroin they sell cocaine
they sell
LSD they and like there's rules like
it's only two and a half grams that you
can get of coke at a time and like
that's
like I don't know if it's like legal or
they just decrim ize it but like there's
a weird but you go to a [__]
store like it's what would have happened
can you have imagine like what what do
you think would happen if you were
around legal cocaine you know how people
rob banks yeah me and you would have
been robbing stores this
[__] give me all the [__] Coke Give
me the give me everything the labels the
syringes it's a different [__] world
man it's
my friend was any of it like when you
were doing coke was any of it like any
of the like fun part about it like the
fact that it was illegal and like kind
of cre not creepy but like you have to
be sneaky or or do you just like Coke it
took me a long time to get a medical
marijuana license I was getting chewed
on for years about getting medical
marijuana license and I tried to explain
to people that I'm talking about a
somebody who's a
civilian
okay you know I was a civilian for a
long time and I remember like Monday
through Thursday was no big deal trust
me I always smoke
pot we got it from somewhere in Colorado
or whatever at that age but Fridays and
Saturdays are something different let's
say you're a roofer okay when I roof
with those guys on Friday days we left a
half hour early you stop you get a
12pack of beer or a sixpack of beer
there's three guys in there they're
drinking I'm driving right right I drop
one of the guys
off and he lives in the neighborhood as
my pot dealer so I stop in there my
check is cashed I get my weed for the
weekend not even for the week I know
it's just going to be for the weekend
and there's something about driving
home drinking that beer that makes you
feel like you are breaking the [__]
law and then you go home and you have to
grind it up and roll it and smoke it and
it's like a like what the Indians used
to do they call like a ceremony you know
okay really turns into that and now you
want me to stop that whole little thing
walk into a weed store like I'm walking
into 7-Eleven to get a pound of ham and
now I'm getting an ounce of weed and
some [__] lollipops
it really even me it took me a long time
to
adjust because just for that little
element of danger just driving home with
an ounce in your car or you know I had a
friend that uh got off of work with his
friend and they were driving home and
his friend said do you mind if I stop in
this
Diner to this bookie and the guy goes my
friend said yeah and when he came out
they drove a block and the car got
pulled off the guy went in for
Coke so my buddy got arrested he got
charged with because the guy put the
coke under the seat so both of you get
arrested really yeah so my point being
that it was part of the whole [__]
thing like when I was doing coke bro
listen I would wake up in the morning
and go today I'm not gonna do Coke you
know like today I'm not doing I'm not
doing it today and 2:00 I'm not doing it
6:00 came I'm not doing it I'm just
going to go do my spot at the store and
go home but my spot's at
11:40 okay lot of [__] mileage to
kill and some nights I had a gig with
Felipe or George Perez or all the crazy
Mexicans down in uh you know off the
five and that kept me but if I was
sitting there by a quarter to eight my
body would change my chemistry would
change I couldn't hear you like when you
were talking to me I couldn't hear you
because now my mind went
into how am I going to get
Coke and I wanted to get it before I got
to The Comedy Store so when I got off
stage I had it in my pocket I didn't go
I didn't have to hunt it
down and from the time 8 o00
came I couldn't control myself it was
something that till this day baffles me
I've written about it everything it was
like no matter what told me I didn't
want to hear it no matter what you told
me I wasn't going to stop to get the
Coke and I would I wouldn't even stop
for red lights in those days I would go
to the ATM in front of rock and roll
rals pull over right on [__]
Sunset never got in trouble I would go
to the ATM pick money up make a U-turn
go down lebrea and go to my dealer's
house right
there and you were never scared like
like just a the idea of having like
buying cocaine would be scary but then
like having it on me like like the fact
that you had it on you during your sets
I would be like consumed like what if
the cops stopped me after this no you
know I told you that when I came here it
took me three years just to just took me
like a year and a half just to think and
write and at the same time I'm writing
the book guys I'm writing the book and
at the same time I'm trying to figure
out what the [__] happened in my life
like how did I go from [__] uh a guy
that quit comedy now that everybody
wants to take a picture with me it was
surreal it was very
surreal and I thought about a time when
I used to right a year before I stopped
snorting I had a dealer that was on the
street I didn't even know his name I
didn't even call him all I went was to
Sunset and Western and I pulled into the
McDonald's and made a u-turn and I
stopped in front of the Home Depot there
was a light and he would come running
from the side streets you can't [__]
believe this [__] and he would come to
the car the driver's side even though
there was another car waiting for a red
light right
there sometimes he was
barefoot sometimes he had a
bicycle sometimes he had sneakers on he
was Spanish didn't speak no English he
pulled up to the car and he immediately
put a Coke Rock in your nose to make
sure you were in a
cop and even though I knew him like Hey
How You Doing sometimes he would just go
what do you want I go give me $60 worth
and he would just go in a bag of rocks
take it out right there at the light and
put it in your
hand and I would have to drive home with
the [__] thing in my hand and
Meanwhile my hand is sweaty and the coke
is starting to [__] melt on my hand
it it
Jesus it's surreal like where' this guy
come from what was his name I figured
out where I met him I met him behind
elen Padre one night
outside and after that it was like
[__] he he was everywhere when you
needed him so I have so many crazy Lee
nobody would believe something like that
well how how do you just meet a homeless
drug dealer behind a Mexican restaurant
we were back that's where Ralphie used
to live that building oh okay I thought
you were just I thought you were in like
we're behind el padre about 1 in the
morning hanging out we it was like four
of us in the circle I don't remember who
was in that Circle till this day but it
had to be like Teddy Ralphie and all a
sudden he came broke up the circle and
started giving us Coke in our
noses and then that's that's how I met
him I'm like [__] you're a godsend who
walks up to you and puts a Coke Rock in
your [__] nose you know what I'm
saying like a fairy did you it was
[__] God it was like and then he
disappeared I didn't see him for like
two weeks then one day I saw him on
Western at two in the
morning and did you ever like go and
like do your little routine and then not
have him not show up or did he
always every time I drove there I think
I went there maybe 12 times the last
year I was doing drugs and he was out
all 12 times one time he was in a tree
it was [__] insane man it was [__]
insane this guy it was and I probably
got 20 stories like that but that's the
one that really
like I was like I went to a UFC fight
one time with Joe Joe was working
2005 2004 okay right I'm sitting there
minding my own business the guy behind
me won't shut the [__] up about The
Longest Yard oh like I can't watch the
fight he keeps tapping me hey how long
were you there for hang out with Kevin
Nash you know did you get to do that
after about the 20th question I just got
up I didn't I didn't even know what the
UFC was I know Chuck Liddell was
fighting and as I was walking in the
hallway of the UFC some guy just comes
up to me and starts talking to me in
Spanish like he knows me and all a
sudden he did know a friend of mine a
friend of mine was there and he did know
him and he came up to me he goes if you
ever need something called his number
I'll bring it up to your room whoa and
the next time I was in Vegas I called
him up and it was in my room he would
bring you an eightball for $120 and then
he' give you like three sleeping pills
and couple Xanaxes and a Codine or
something oh codeine's fun look this
[__] it was crazy I would get to
Vegas and call him and he go call me
when you're ready so once I would do the
show with Joe and I go back to the hotel
I call him and within 30 minutes he was
there he'd tell me like 18 minutes I'll
be there I'm right next
door do you think you attracted Coke to
you like because like do people just
know that you like I don't know how well
the guy he was with in me had done a few
bumps a couple
times okay when I saw him with him I'm
like ah this guy must be hell too and
then the guy started talking to me on
the
side it's [__] crazy I don't know
what that guy's name is I still talk to
the guy that I did bumps with from time
to time he lives in Newark now and next
time I talk to him I'll ask him I go who
the [__] was that
guy and did they keep in touch with you
like if they saw you were coming to do
shows did you ever get calls like yeah
they would call me if I was going to La
they would call if they would come to La
for the weekend they get them tickets
iny store and they give me a
present was it hard like the first do
you remember the first time you got
offered Coke after you
quit
um I don't
remember well not even in the first time
but like was it hard like the when off C
that like two months after I quit some
guy called me that I knew from The
Comedy Store okay he man I got a problem
I got $3,000 I need some
coke
now
if he would have caught me the last year
I would have taken that three grand he
would have never seen me right because
the guy wouldn't have done nothing and I
was that [__] crazy at that time but
I would never you know it was like
within two months God gave me a test of
two people who called me said they
wanted to meet me I met them and they
showed up with not $300 but 3,000 5,000
I go where the [__] were you when I
cuz I would have filled that bag with
aspirins and crushed it up and then
argued I don't know what the guy's name
is he came up to me on a
bicycle that's wild that you just like
obviously stealing is never like the
right thing to
do but just knowing hearing stories
about you and then having someone come
up to you I have a problem I have to get
$3,000 wor a Coke and I have the cash
that's like I'll never forget that I
still remember who the comic was he's
still in La he was like my friend really
needs it he'll give you this whatever
you could do and I'm like oh where were
you a [__] year and a half
ago holy [__] yeah that I I've always
been afraid like you know we did a lot
of stuff on the church I've never done
Coke I don't it's always like kind of
scared me like just like even before the
fenel stuff the idea of like snorting
something I don't know it's
it's it's one of the scarier ones to me
it's you should be scared and I'm happy
that you never did it and I'm happy that
you're never gonna do it you know it's
it's
uh look what look what it's
caused you know
I I was with a friend of mine this
weekend and tight friend of mine we grew
up together you know he's my
brother and you
know he had a son his son is still he
still has a son but the sun cleaned up
and we were talking about and you know
this guy was telling me [__] and I'm
like I had to stop saying to him like
Mike what the [__] did we do at that age
right you know and granted listen the
stakes were always high
God knows when you're going to do a
blast of coke and somebody's going to
die of a heart
attack you know God knows now what
you're GNA do and you could just die
from
fentanyl whether it's smoking weed
whether it's eating a [__] gummy you
don't know the company you have to be
very careful in your surroundings today
and today's and I speak this to young
kids as much as I can it's over the days
of us in the 70s buying Quay luds at a
club it it's [__] over I wouldn't do
it and I'm
crazy I would [__] do it and I'm out
of my tits I would not [__] do it
right now I don't want to you know how
many nights I had party think
about from
1980 to
2007 how many of those kns were in a
room with six or seven people talking
nonsense or four people talking non
nonsense what if I would have [__]
woke up what if I would have went to bed
one night and wake up in the morning one
of those people were dead I couldn't
shake that I would never get fired I
would never you know that's it I I look
at life now now if I team up with you
and we meet two girls in Vancouver and
we get and we get Coke at the pharmacy
and right now I I don't I wouldn't even
put somebody in my room no it's very you
know what it something happened to me
this weekend and I was thinking about
you because a after the show on Saturday
I was walking back I got an
Airbnb I was just walking back and there
was a train
station and uh with a all like a 24-hour
convenience store and as I was walking
by there's home I I don't know if he was
homeless but he was like you know just
kind of like someone who was out he had
bags at night like he like like a night
person and he just came like he fell
through a
door like he just fell and crashed
through a door and like was laying on
the ground making like noises and
groaning and I was I was walking because
I was going to get an Uber because it
was raining and
normally I would like help someone who
like fell through a door and was like
and but he was just laying there he
wasn't bleeding or anything but
just which by the way makes me laugh a I
I feel I get nervous
but I just sat there and I didn't know
what to do so I didn't like and there
was another like homeless guy who didn't
say anything to him and he was just kept
moaning and H and I I just got in my
Uber and I left but like I felt
bad I just love this poor old like he
wasn't old but he was like probably
40s laying on the ground I'm laughing
because I think of all my years running
around getting in trouble even for the
even for kidnapping all listen I think
the worst thing I ever did I was
about it was the night it was about the
week Freddy Prince died okay it was
[__] cold as [__] it was January I
was a
kid I was pissed about Freddy Prince and
Me and three of my brothers me and maybe
two other
guys three other guys were walking home
my mother was still alive that lived on
given that
Terrace and we're like by 76th Street on
Kenedy
Boulevard right there's the high
school's there like 74th Street the high
school's right there but the high
school's like the whole block okay and
we walk we walk we walk and by the time
we get there's a border of Ed parking
garage in the
back and by the time me and these two I
don't even know what we were talking
about
I think we were maybe coming from a
movie that's what it was when we'd leave
a movie in Fair View
cinema we'd have to walk like 10 blocks
to North Bergen and then the bus didn't
come because the snow or Jersey somebody
got mugged in Jersey City or something
we would start walking and and then the
we'd see the bus going up so we knew the
bus would be coming down within 30
minutes and we just keep walking to stay
warm right and I'll never forget we're
walking and we hit the border V and
right there I started
[Music]
hearing he was saying are you that means
help me in Spanish right so me and my
four buddies three buddies were walking
and we're [__] nerds the guys with at
the time in North B these guys are nerds
you
know and I remember like I wanted to
help the guy he was hammered he didn't
fall he was just [__] drunk as [__]
and one of the guys said let's roll him
you know let's take his money and [__]
the guy's like H were you like 11 or 12
yeah we tried to help him the guy like I
can't and one of us put our hands in his
pocket and that guy came to life
Jack and we started kicking him in The
Chins and
[__] he went right down yelling I are
you the man we just started running it I
never saw him I didn't go to church for
like a month after that I was like
they're going to catch me in church and
[__] oh my god
oh Jesus Christ it is funny well I don't
know what it is and I feel bad but when
people fall and make that noise it does
it is pretty funny let me tell you
something I did a lot of funny things
with you we went to a lot of funny
cities okay so this day there is a night
I will never
forget and that's the night in San
Francisco with the homeless guy with the
dog oh my God yeah San Jose I think was
that San Francisco
Sisco Mexican kid we were with the
Spanish kid but right but we had just
done the punchline and we just went to
7-Eleven to get a snack and we're
standing in front of the 7-Eleven we're
not bothering
anybody the guy comes out with a [__]
dog right
and the is barking I don't know what was
going on and we're just giggling and I
think the guy went left and then he came
back and he goes [__] you you guys are
laughing at my dog and that's when we
started going off we I started doing the
lines from Raging Bull Larry I'm gonna
go over there and eat that [__]
dog and the guy was like [__] you
nobody's eating my dog and he would run
and then he'd come back I dare you to
eat my dog we're like I'm going to come
down there don't make me go over there
cook that [__] dog I'll stab and eat
him right in front of you nobody's
eating my dog whatever the [__] he was
yelling then the neighbor came out
remember the neighbor from across the
street came out somebody came out and
they're like guys you gotta knock it off
people trying to sleep that [__]
wasn't in the house two seconds were
like I'm gonna eat that
[__] didn't you get in a car and like
find him again am I wrong I don't know
what happened that night but it we were
there for like 45
minutes just [__]
howling howling Butch esar me you I
don't know who else was there that was
the weekend we're going to bring you to
Hooker and we couldn't find you and like
where were you you like I was making the
bed we [__] no you kept calling me you
knew where I was you kept calling me
that one I think was San Jose I don't
know yeah Jose CA you because Butch told
us about back door or whatever Back Page
and back door is a different website but
back page and you kept like he kep sh by
the way I love that you told Joe about
boy a Hoy [__] killed me um but he he
kept showing us and he kept telling us
about like an old lady that he would
like hook up with oh and you told me you
kept telling me and it was like when you
would I would get really high and you'd
call me and you'd tell me the police
were coming but don't answer the door
and you would just keep calling and it I
knew the weren't coming but it would get
into my head and so you kept doing that
you come I'm going to get this because I
that was before Paula that was like
before and I was you know [__] nerdy
and single and you kept you kept calling
and you were like I'm she's coming she
and I yeah I F I destroy hotel rooms so
and I was embarrassed to think of and it
is funny to think that why would I care
what a hooker thought of my hotel room
but I was the bed we [__] the B cleaned
I I made I put all my stuff away do you
also remember I think it was another
Colorado guy like um a x UFC guy who you
sent me a picture of a woman with a
tattooed
[__] and you said I had to get on a
flight to go and she was going to go
fart to my face and I was like who would
tattoo an [__] and I [__] I had a
bag packed cuz I never knew there's
something you that's I that's the thing
you don't know about Joey is that he
says when he's [__] with you and when
he's telling this the truth it's the
same face you know like you just you
have such a good poker face and I don't
know like sometimes like weird [__]
would happen and I like we would just go
somewhere randomly so I'm like am I
going to Colorado to like it was it was
a picture of a girl with a t Barb Water
Tattoo around her
[__] and you and you like that's the
thing is you you [__] link other
people into your [__] torture you had
him messaging me oh I have ready for you
I'm like I don't want a girl who's
[__] with a tattoo on
it oh my God I remember the chick with
the Bob White [__] tattoo oh you
couldn't fathom a a girl's tattoo when
her ass but no I couldn't fathom I still
can't I still can't so someone has to
hold does she hold her ass cheeks open
and then I can't imagine getting your
[__] tattooed I have nothing against
tattoos well we'll take some edibles on
Saturday night and we'll see if you want
to get your [__] tattoos I've never
been that's the thing like that I don't
understand when people like where they
get [__] up and they pretend like
they're flying and they jump off of a
balcony I've never been so high when I
get high I just [__] you've seen it I
pass
out I don't I can't [__] I don't
think about doing weird
[__] that's because you're a nice kid
you know what I'm saying you ain't got
no mental problem problems well that's
not that's not true [__] sitting
there last night okay watching the news
was on CNN or one of those [__]
things and I don't know if my wife was
watching you know maybe she had Netflix
on and she turned it
off I walked into it like about 10 ah
maybe 1020 and they were talking about
that kid that the parents bought him the
gun oh [__] went to school and now she's
getting charged with involuntary man
Slaughter it's a good call you know
but you know man I don't know that CH
child or in other words I don't know
that [__] little [__] but I can
tell by looking at
him that he ain't right you could tell
he ain't right his parents God know you
know they're like any other parent today
that's young they're on Instagram also
they're not paying attention you
know and they buy the kid a gun he
shoots the school he shoots I don't know
how many kids I wouldn't even listen to
it but I think it was there did he did
they buy him a gun or it was their
gun they bought him a gun [__] or some
[__] but if you look at this kid and I'm
not trying to be funny or cute you could
tell that there's [__] issues there
and there's goddamn problems you know
I'm scared now I'm petrified because I
don't know what kids do on a computer so
like tonight she comes home from
kickboxing right at
530 she changes she goes right
upstairs I go up there every 45
minutes to just check on her just to ask
her a stupid question but I'm really
looking at the computer and you're
looking at your kids' rooms and you and
and I know when I was a kid my mom was
always in there snooping and as I got
older my mom was always in there
snooping well and I I'm sure you might
you might just not know but does your
wife have a thing that like keeps track
of everything she does on
there well there's no there's a block on
stuff okay yeah and she's really good
with the games we were friends with that
guy in California who made the games
uhhuh so whenever Mercy comes with a
game my wife will call that dude and say
what do you think about this game he'll
go don't let it go on there she could do
this on there they could crack the
screen they could do you know so we as
much as we can because listen you and I
both know when you were grow it's like
that song by [__] James addiction we
have more influence with your children
than you
do yeah you know and that's just
something that is a [__] reality you
know like that's it I when I was [__]
14 I love basketball if [__] Michael
Corin would have told me Jesus was
Puerto Rican I would have believed him
you know if if Julius Irving told me to
jump off a bridge that i' learn how to
jump high I would believe him you know
so I know that children are
impressionable and that's you know and
you look at these things and you go you
know what my actions are not being a uh
uh I'm not being a like a
[__] nosy parent I'm just concerned
that she's not up there watching
[__] Hamas raping people whatever the
[__] you know you can find anything I
don't think you're being a nosy parent I
think that's like a what a good parent
does I I think you have to I mean
especially like the internet really
isn't a place for like kid like it's a
like even even the games Athena kids
play Roblox like that they people can
message you they can friend you it's not
good like it's it's not and this is I
know everyone talks about Taylor Swift
now I have nothing against Taylor Swift
but I Don't Remember Loving anything the
way I see like people love like Athena's
kid her girls it's like when the like
you know how like people were like
beating the cars of The
Beatles like that's that's what they
they go crazy when when that she's on
screen watch on foot football like they
go
crazy for like all of it like it's just
I've never seen anything like
that you know she's she's not into
Taylor Swift she's not into American
dolls and she ain't into Disney honest
to God she comes down she watches movies
with me she's into
schoolwork and like I said I'm involved
I'm not on the road so I'm watching I
see her friends I see the friends that
come over I talk to the parents you know
I'm around when she gets off the bus I'm
outside when she gets on the bus I'm
outside my wife is outside in the
morning I'm outside in the afternoon but
I wave at her from the window I watch
and I go out there because people could
just follow a bus your kid get dropped
off and a car just your day or today
somewhere some guy tried to haul an 11
year old girl so [__] I'm not even
talking about I'm talking about my child
as a [__] safety concern like you
know having a weapon up there whether I
had a boy or a girl you know they just
but you could see those kids are [__]
up and I had grew up with [__] up kids
but they weren't [__] up like that kid
I saw on the screen that's a different
type of [__] up that's like a he had
no friends alienation type of dude was
always on the computer Le let me tell
you
something I've never gone into the dark
web I don't use the dark web if you know
anything about my computer
savviness n you know me that I don't
know anything about
anything if if you go through my [__]
things on the computer it's all Health
[__] right benefits of eating carrots
for men over 60 benefits for a thumb up
your ass for men over 60 you know how
many times how many hours a week that's
that's 90% of the [__] you'll find
you'll find some [__] on
jiujitsu a lot of [__] on
music you know I just got over the
holidays I don't know what happened
like uh the 24th the 25th and something
like that somebody used my ATM card to
get uPorn uh not uPorn the other one
where the girls you charge you a month
chatter bank or only fans what is it
only only and I told my wife my wife's
like are you crazy I go how long you
know me I go go upstairs and call the
[__] bank and they'll tell you you
know and I told I said in before the
pandemic only fans was contacting a lot
of comedians yeah and offering them
deals to come
over okay I didn't know what only fans
was I had no idea you were talking to me
a little bit about patreon but you knew
I didn't like it early on the church or
anything and I remember that I there was
a girl at the store one night that was
very nice not my type but she was
telling me she was on only fans and I
said to her so you on only fans as a
comedian and she goes no I show my
titties on there so when only fans
approached me three months later or
whatever and I'll never forget I I
signed up for a thing just to see what
she put on there Jesus Christ it was
completely different than what I
anticipated and I canceled it at the end
of 30 days and I never thought about it
again so I told my wife I guarantee it's
one of those charges she went back she
goes yeah you this is like
2019 you signed up why would they be
charging you now but that I don't even
know anybody on only fans right I
believe you but it
is it is I could see other people being
like yeah you know someone just stole my
credit card I had $800 of only pin
subscriptions and what they did the Bank
of America what they did was they knew
that they saw those charges uhhuh and
they denied a different charge on me
that's what made me go the bank and the
lady goes you have to call only fans
when she said it to me I was so [__]
embarrassed I don't have to tell you I
was so [__] embarrassed so I came
home I talked to my wife about it she's
like yeah now they got but I don't even
go on that stuff I don't you know I
don't do anything on that I don't uh
look into guns or weapons or why would I
why would I it was weird I know you're I
know you're probably not even a huge
porn guy but in
Virginia I was you're not allowed to go
on like porn sites well not something
that you're not allowed but you have to
like give them a picture of your
ID like could you imagine giving your
pictures of of ID to go look at like
pornnhub like PornHub doesn't even work
in Virginia and the other ones you have
to literally make an account and take a
picture of your ID to prove you're over
18 I don't have the
time I don't want I don't want to give
my to a porns anything I sign up for my
wife does it any apps I have to download
for a project or anything anything
Weight
Watches the the classes I take now on
Tuesdays all that [__] she downloads all
that stuff my breath work [__] app
you know just so I don't know what's
going on I'll sign up for years next
thing you know they're taking
$200,000 I'm on minus [__]
$199,000 because I don't know what I'm
[__] doing right that's that's why I
keep what I'm doing I I figured out how
to Google
things you know I what do you mean you
figured it out yeah go you go to Google
and you press enter yeah but I don't
know like sometimes I'm looking for a
friend of mind that I maybe did time
with I get high at night and I start
thinking about [__] I go let me find if
I can find this guy nine out of 10 I
can't find them whether I'm feeling
lucky or I go on the Google search you
know I don't even know what to press
right
golech I'm feeling lucky it's just the
first result like the first
result what's so like when you go to
Google if you hit I'm feeling lucky
whatever the first link is is the one
that it's going to open and if you
think a crazy [__] like me is
gonna go on
uh like a page of
weapons and try to look I was raised I
would never even go through that because
that waves a flag listen yeah they tell
you that the internet's not monitored
but it is oh [__] yeah it is when you go
who told you it wasn't monitored well
that's what it's supposed to be not
really monitored like you know you keep
going to a page to how to make a [__]
shoe bomb eventually somebody's gonna
knock on your [__] door you know what
I'm saying you try it try it three or
four times how to make an explosive nut
track [__] uh you know I got big
balls I might as well put a bomb in my
nut sack how do I do you hit that Google
search three times somebody will knock
on your [__] door hell yeah and I
don't you know this is just me talking
to you so there's no crazy communication
on my pages like this you know why why
it's like stealing a car if the cops
pull you over you're in it the evidence
you're in it you're sitting on it right
so you just it's a [__] vehicle for
me to read
[__] I'm lazy sometimes so I just want
to cut through the
[__] and uh that's it I would love to
look at your Google searches though I
feel like there might be a couple funny
ones oh to know what you Google [__]
uh fungi
toenail remedies you know i' I've
Googled that search that's my heaviest
[__] search is in search of how to
cure the fungi toenail and it's only two
ways you could read a thousand pages and
there's two ways either stick your feet
and gine and light them on
fire station and then you piss blood for
two years you
know holy [__] have could you cut the
toenail off and let it regrow or would
it is it just in there been doing here
for the last 10 years no but the whole
toenail now I got one on the right one
and when I got one on the left one and
every time you cut them smoke comes out
of them it is tremendous I don't I don't
cut him just to cut him to see the smoke
come out of it like it's like the the
fungi flies up in the air I love it and
then I sand them down I know I'm
embarrassed to even go to Jiu-Jitsu with
my [__] lizard feet but what am my
options to go in there with [__]
sandals and [__] oh my God I I do
remember I was thinking about you this
week too you might know where I'm going
with this like the three weeks I did
Jiu-Jitsu we rolled once and I got my I
I've had a callous on my big toe for
[__] 35 I don't know as long all all
my life and I got you with it and you
called it the the outfitz toe you said
it was like my superpower
move you said I could win every
tournament that was the football that
was the the [__] foot your
grandfather used an
NWI would stop this no he would just
kick him next kick him with that to the
years the toe got harder and harder you
know oh it it gets you I [__] got
Athena's a kid with it the other day by
accident she like oh you put a hole in
my
skin really I didn't no she wasn't
bleeding or anything but she I we were
playing around and and it like it
touched her
and so far I'm up to 800 milligrams you
know oh my God so far it's just another
day in the
park it's Monday these [__]
don't know went to red light therapy
today I changed my whole [__]
molecular cell
structure got shot I got in Texas going
through my [__] body now the stem
cell IV are you gonna keep doing that
can you do that in New
Jersey that's interesting does do your
knees feel
better no okay not so far it takes time
right that makes sense it takes time you
know but they feel better like I gave
them a lot I waited a week and then I
gave him a lot of blood for three days I
[__] rode the bikes I put some weight
on it and then uh now they feel a little
better than last week I'm not doing
nothing crazy I'm not squatting nothing
like that it's all walking stairs and
going jiujitsu and lifting at the gym
I'm not doing no [__] nothing crazy
I'm just trying to stay alive like
trying to laugh have a good
time last week I ate a bag of dicks on
stage oh really brutal but I did try to
DET turban
joke that
didn't they didn't like it ah you know
that was one of my darkest
fantasies you know I went to my
daughter's uh recital Tuesday
night and you know my daughter's Irish
she's a half breed so she's got the
Cuban blood this
so you know they gave her at least it's
in [__] league right drums but they
gave this Indian kid like the triangle
and I'm sitting there the whole [__]
thing and I'm going why' they give this
poor [__] little Indian kid the
triangle you know what I'm saying like
why why couldn't they give him a [__]
he's a natural on the flute you know
little flute with a snake and those
sandals that are pointy and [__] that
[__] be over there like what's
his name what's the what's the
guy that with long hair Jay-Z's cousin
the white dude with the long hair we
were kids Jay-Z's i i a Rick Rubin no he
has like he plays the [__] whatever I
don't know anyone who plays the flute
like in 1995 I was in a restaurant in
Seattle and he was there I forget what
his [__] name is a musician
he whatever anyway it don't f
but can you imagine if they actually
gave the the Indian kid a flute that
that would be front page news if they
made an Indian kid play the flute if
they an
Indian why he's a natural somebody in
his [__] culture went to a carnival
and played the flute at some I'm not
trying to be cute here but every time
you see Indians they're playing like the
little flute and the snakes trying to
come out of the hat and
all I've never SE SE this I've never
seen one Indian with a flute before the
[__] you been it's all over the
cartoons goes to
India oh holy [__] oh my God the poor
kid and he probably he probably just
stunk why you gonna give the poor
Indian I like the kid I know the kid he
lives like two doors down I like the kid
but I was pissed off handsome kid smart
as a [__] whip why didn't did you go
to him and say why don't you ask for the
flute no cuz then he's going to go wi
the flute and I got to break it down his
family tree he's Americanized plus one
now he don't even know about flutes or
snakes the sandals he's got a little let
me tell you something then there's
another Indian family that goes to
Jiu-Jitsu with Mercy the mom is [__]
cool as [__] the dad always comes up to
me I'm gonna bring my friend from work
he's a big fan and uh but the kids man
they're going to be M because they're
like Americanized uhhuh they're going to
be models both of them both he's
handsome as [__] he's got a nice little
head do and she's going to just be
Americanized beautiful Indian girl
beautiful American Indians
beautiful so right so they didn't but
they didn't like the turban joke what
else like how did it feel to bomb did it
feel bad did you like it like what what
were you going through there was a
reaction from my body I didn't [__] my
pants I didn't pull a Bert but there was
a reaction like I
not that I started sweating but I found
myself and I put myself there to see how
it feels you know but this week I plan
to go out two
nights I plan to go two nights bre ER
invited me Friday and Saturday to
bananas East Rutherford tomorrow I got a
spot I'm going to and then uh you'll be
here on Saturday yeah I'll be there all
weekend somebody invited me to a show
Saturday like a not a page show it's
like an open mic in a bar and he's got
something maybe Thursday night so if I
could pop two out of [__] three I'm
good then hopefully I'll see you
Saturday night and [__] uh we can eat
some edibles and kill the rest of these
mushrooms and [__] we can have a nice
breakfast oh I can't wait over at
[__] Stacks I can't wait um did you
when you were bombing like did was it is
it
discouraging did you did you get upset
like oh maybe I shouldn't do stand
up
no okay
no no no not even [__] close before
we get into this conversation let me
take a a quick little break here I want
to talk to you guys about DraftKings the
Super Bowl and I want to talk to you
guys about hello fresh and the chicken
bologan you can make at home give me two
minutes Lee what's happening Savages
listen are you looking for a super offer
for superbow 58 well Uncle Joey's got
the answer you ready draftking sports
book has you covered new customers bet
on the big game listen to this five
bucks turns into 200 bucks instantly in
bonus bets I mean before you can say Tip
Top mooo you got the quick deuce in your
account right there ready to go for
totals and overs and unders and you're
going to love it but first first
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now and use code Joey J OE y new
customers bet $5 to get 200 instantly in
bonus beds like that you understand me
only on draftking sports book an
official sports betting partner of Super
Bowl 58 with code Joey now if you got a
camon problem call 1800 Gambler or in
West Virginia who the [__] lives in West
Virginia call
www.com one800 gambler. net in New York
call
8778 Hope New York
or text Hope New York
369 listen 21 over the play varies under
jurisdiction void onario bonus bets
expired 168 hours after insur after get
them C dk.com
for eligibility and deposit restrictions
just know one thing with DraftKings you
got the crown and the checkin is brought
to you by hello fresh listen last week I
had some of the chicken bolanz it was
tremendous and guess what I made it
myself trying to save some change and
eat better hello fresh can help stop
eating like a kid and start taking
better care of yourself
helloof fresh since farm fresh
ingredients and seasonal recipes right
to your door no waiting in line at the
grocery store whether you're a vegan
counting calories a pescatarian or
looking for a large family cooking for a
large family helloof fresh has plans to
suit your lifestyle like I said listen I
had the chicken bowl Ines I made last
week my wife liked it I liked it I don't
even like chicken but with the bowl and
as it worked and I'll tell you
hellofresh is tremendous so do me a
favor go to hellofresh.com
joyfree j o e y f re e and pressing code
Joey free for free breakfast for Life
how's that one breakfast item per box
while subscription is active that's free
breakfast for life at hellofresh.com
jooy free with code Joey free hello
fresh America's number one meal kit now
back to the checkin we're back [__]
beautiful Tuesday morning here with my
man lee sayat so you were asking
me I was asking you I asked you if uh
when you were bombing like if at all you
got a little bit discouraged and thought
like because you you have this 10 set
thing and you want to see how it goes
like is that is the fact that one of
them was a bomb like did it bum you out
not even
close Okay no reason to bum yet it made
me like it even more it made me go to
the
notebook and write a little more that's
what you do when you bump you don't
blame it on the sound you don't blame it
on the audience you don't blame it on
your head do or your
sweatpants you did something wrong so
I'm sticking to my word and I [__]
went home and I wrote three other things
I tossed the [__]
gay Catholic sing a joke it's not
working it's just not getting
them uh I'm definitely tossing the
napkin joke I don't have a closer for
that one yet and it hits too close to
home I don't want my wife to see me
doing that joke okay I added some other
that I'll try this
week and like do you like let's imagine
the opposite like let's say after
whatever it's been a year of not doing
standup you went back and you were just
killing every time would like would that
be boring like would you not like it if
you were killing every every
set listen who doesn't like to kill
right but if you know anything about me
after the fourth to fifth set I'd be
suspect so and that's why I to do that's
why I want to do droping open mics they
don't know nothing nobody knows nothing
it's Comics it's not people who would
usually come to see me
I'm doing that for a reason there's
little things that I do that you go he's
a [__] you know everybody's probably
looking at me going he's an idiot he
could be getting paid [__] big money
for these I'd rather not I'd rather just
have a good time go back to basics
relearn some stuff listen whoever
doesn't like
creating is [__] crazy if I'm a baker
right now and I go to some restaurant
and I eat the coconut cake and it's
three times better than mine I'm going
to ask for the Baker and I'm going to go
listen I'm a baker in New York what you
put in this [__] cake it's delicious
and they'll say well I added a little
lemon lemon juice I let it sit overnight
and then you add it to yours that's
creating yeah you know you look a
picture on a wall you've been painting
this [__] thing for a year and all of
a sudden people telling you it's
beautiful but you know there's something
missing and needs color when you're when
you [__] do it and it
works there's no better
feeling and you take like I watched
those stupid Sylvester stallon Stallone
movies when I was in I had [__] I
couldn't sleep and I was watching this
one movie and it made a lot of sense
it's one step it's one punch and it's
one
round it's one step it's one punch it's
one round that's all you should be
worrying about
but as young Comics now I gotta worry
about social media I got to take a
picture with [__] Joe Rogan and get
it on my [__] website there's so much
other [__] what I'm trying to do with
the book and with you when we talk is
bringing it back to basics you want to
be a good comic that's let's start there
when it's start when it's time to
[__] shine on social media we'll get
to that level these are all levels when
you start mixing them you know you had a
very interesting question this morning
okay which I thought about all
day and I kind of felt hypocritical
about the answer I gave
you when you're young and somebody takes
they want to notice you you know it's
always great to take a meeting with them
and speak to them and you know whatever
and see what they're looking to do but n
times if there anybody they'll make
contact with you come watch you and if
there's some if you sayy something
special in you they'll check on you
every 90
days okay and make not on you I remember
when I got to La I wanted to manage it
so bad there was a guy that was he had
clients they were all working on TV and
they were all working as acting
comics and I took a meeting with him
okay so
wolf and I'll never forget that when I
sat down he went into he turned around
and in his [__] file he had a file
with my name on it and all the sets he
had seen me with the results and what he
thought whoa the guy didn't sign me he
ended up quitting the business and
becoming a millionaire with a do company
or
something asked Josh about him but he
had his clients were good his clients I
still remember their names I'm not going
to drop them he had clients that at the
time were [__] doing great things and
film and television and they were all at
the store and he was at the store every
night you know but it was very
impressive that he had watched me and
paid attention and the dates were
accurate I was at those places that's
that's so organiz again
that's it's really tough like you're
were talking
about like an episode or two ago about
like not being
desperate and like when you like when
you said that guy didn't book Sign
you if someone doesn't sign you right
away is it like it just see like it
would bum me I I how long did it take
you to not get affected emotionally by
that
stuff listen man it's at the time I had
the store so all that [__] was just
humps and bumps I would B the MIT sure
to manage me like MIT when are you going
to manage me ah I don't have time for
that and all that [__] you know and I
remember I signed with a manager who's a
great guy I still talk to him today I
don't think he was prepared for
Hollywood okay I was more aggressive and
then I signed with a guy who was very
good and until today I thank him for I
thank him for
my I thank Jeff
because he showed me the importance of
filming
television and I saw it and I ran with
the advice he gave me and what he taught
me when he signed me I was a glorified
feature he didn't pull no punches he
goes I'm not going to make any money
with you $500 a week right in my
pocket that's not money to me so if you
want to be with me you got to start
acting just go get a couple jobs then
come back to me and I booked baseball
and the pilot and I bumped into him at a
commercial and I bumped into him at a
parking lot The Improv and I told him he
goes let's set up a meeting let me get
the reals when I got there he had all my
tape already and he goes let's work on
this let's work on that he had a [__]
plan yeah that's like that's what I'm
looking for we went right
from acting class like there's usually
like a little period where people milk
you and
[__] not him I think I might third
audition I was sitting in the room with
[__] movie stars I was like oh
no [__] like education I got from being
with him those three years of auditions
from
99 to maybe
2003 I thought I wasn't doing any work
but he was getting me into rooms with
big time people because he believed in
me and I didn't book that job that day
but then he those people would see me
again and now I went to
producers and then they would see me
again and I would go to producers on
everything until one day I just busted
three of them you know it was like taxi
a Longest Yard there was like three big
things I did because I just didn't get
those I had been working on those it was
the sameon got the same casting
directors they all meet and talk about
lead I just had this little Jewish kid
leis Sayad he was chubby he dance in the
room anybody know I saw him at the
Improv last month I kind of liked him
maybe we'll call him in for another
meeting and then you come in and your
hands are shaking and they'll go listen
we love you but you're still a big green
but we'll be thinking about
you and then nine months later you see
him and you got two more
credits and now you you more confident
in the room and that time you won't get
it and went to a big time name but the
next next time you're going to [__]
bang it
out
it's because you talk about this is the
best time of your like your favorite
time of your career like that's the I
think hard part you do I mean I've heard
you and a lot of Headliners talk about
like the open mic feature levels like
your you're the time you look back on
with like the most fondness for a
variety of
reasons but as someone who's there right
now it's like I think it's when you
start anything it's like to to get
someone to take a
first uh Faith like have a faith in you
and take a chance on you is like so hard
to get like at the be it's just you you
feel like you're there and then no
people just like I don't know they don't
believe not they don't believe in you
but they they don't want to take the
risk well here's how come I believe it
because I saw
it not with me I saw it with Bobby Lee
I saw with Steve runers easy I saw with
Punky the girl from s
live I saw with I I can't tell you how
many
people I can't tell you how many people
I saw one day when they were living with
four people and the next day they were
living in a [__] Mansion Ralphie
May I I saw it I saw the I saw the
Miracles and once you see the Miracles
you feel different ly you go oh [__]
most people go [__] Lee he's not even
funny he's got that [__] car it's
because he was on that podcast for nine
years no what you're supposed to say is
I'm happy for [__] Lee I'm gonna
start drinking the same thing he was
drinking I'm gonna start doing what he
was doing I'm gonna cheer him on that
doesn't mean I'm gonna be in his back
pocket to see what I could get from him
I'm gonna cheer him on and that's what I
did with Ralphie me and Ralphie were
slept on the same floor you know for
four five let me see Ralphie
hit when I hit the longest yard Ralphie
was all he had Just One Last Comic
Standing and he had just done a month at
the Harris or some [__] whoa and he
would he had already moved from the
apartment he was on Beverly now he was
eating [__] sushi at that place on
Beverly he was [__] driving two new
cars he had a pound of weed on his
dresser in the living room that little
coffee table there was a pound of weed
in there at all times you just went over
there opened it up and took a butt out
of it and rolled the joint it was
unbelievable when he opened up his doors
to
everybody I still remember when he
bought the house and we were all up
there you know and it was
like holy [__] and then for years he
would come home on Monday
and pick me up and buy me $600 worth of
weed and Edibles and cookies and we go
to eat it Chin
Chin you know we [__] do you know I
saw it I saw Joe Rogan and the show on
NBC thinking he was going to become a
big standup and next thing you know he's
on [__] news radio uh he's on Fear
Factor
right you know out of nowhere and next
thing you know we're doing shows and
going up to his room afterward ordering
room service and talking into some
[__] thing every Saturday every
Friday and I would goof on him dog who
you talking to those who's home on
Friday night 13 year old that are
[__] whacking off looking for free
entertainment that's JRE
today yeah that's [__] JRE
today so you think about what I saw and
what how that makes you a believe
it's like the people in the Bible that
saw Jesus turn bread to [__] you know
fish
right well it's the same thing I saw
human
beings turn nothing into something and
that's [__] big when you see it
that's big
man yeah yeah there's been a couple of
people like in in my class like there's
one guy uh Michael blowstein he does uh
he's part of like the stiff socks
podcast
him and I were doing open mics at the
fourth wall and now he has he has like I
think two soldout nights at the Wilbur
oh The Wilbur yeah yeah that and you see
it you go okay at least I'm on the right
[__]
path because I was rolling with that
[__] so that's the that's your
feather that's what people don't see
young Comics old Comics they don't see
that that that guy just kicked open the
door for you you're not going to go in
his back pocket you're going to get that
energy and do something on your
own very inspiring that's the best thing
you could ever [__] see that listen
man when we first started the podcast
and a year
later we were just selling out one night
a week and if anybody knows me for me
that was good
enough like that sell one night Joey if
I come into your town on a Thursday and
sell it out [__] because I came from a
world where for 20 years I showed up and
there was eight
people right they weren't there to see
me they were there to see Joe so I had
to learn to live with that and that's
strong as a comic because most Comics
would say I'm not going to go there did
to see him anyway no there's an
opportunity for you to learn and to get
better and to open up for a comic and to
face different audiences and secretly
you're building your
audience hopefully yeah because I
remember still talking to AEL and a tell
telling me dog you're doing a great job
as a feature he goes because you're
everywhere every [__] week twice a
year and that means you're building 8 10
11 13 people and guess what they want to
say I knew Lis say at when he was a
feature act opening for Diaz opening for
Josh Wolf I knew he was going to be a
star now when you do get your first
movie they're going to be there [__]
jumping up and down going I was here I
[__] knew what I told you
[__] and that's even a better
[__] feeling that's even [__] you
know it was very inspiring to see like I
because I I was lucky enough to go to a
bunch of your special
tapings um but at that point maybe I
forget what Netflix was what year it was
but I wasn't really into standup at the
time like when I went to Chicago and
then to Vegas like to see him film it it
was just very like I even sat the
theater is great it's like super old and
you can
smoke and there's a staircase and I just
sat and I couldn't see him but I could
hear him and I just smoked the joint and
like listened to him like and he did
great and the shows the shows were fun
but it was just cool for a second to
like
imagine 20 years from now whatever it is
15 years from now that if I get to
record a
special Hey Brother once you're there
and you smell
it and you go okay you know what I can't
do this
tomorrow but it's one day that this is
going to change and I'll be doing one of
these and it's really you
know I don't know it was
uh listen I don't know
I never wanted to be no Big Time comic I
did it to just I don't know but it was
great to see what I
saw and the knowledge I got it it was
[__] amazing from the sets and the
people I was with do you ever think if
you ever thought I was going to do it I
still remember going to see Analyze
That on a date and leaving the movie
theater I went to see it up at uh
Universal City
okay at a
MAA and I remember leaving there
going what the [__] am I doing my
life what the [__] am I doing there was
two movies I went to see and I left
there like what am I
doing uh Jerry Maguire in
Seattle like that feeling that movie
gave me I was like I gotta get into the
movie business that's it I'm going to LA
to get movies but I'm like I'll only be
an extra
and then
uh it was just a couple things I was
like man this is what I want to [__]
do once I got like there was one I
started shooting all those little movies
you know nobody would see but i' take so
much pride in them and I was I could see
I was ahead of the other people like
once I was on I was on at least I knew
what was going on considering where I
came from I never went to an acting
class
I shot two or three movies with no
acting experience not movies but three
or two or three things one being a pilot
that's why you don't see me in the pilot
and uh basball being another I didn't
know what I was doing and then I got
into an acting class and like by
2003 I knew what I was doing now and I
was going up in front of those people
that I was going up in front from 1999
in 2000
and now get farther with them right you
what was it about Jerry Maguire that
inspired you J
Moore really J Moore was a standup from
New
Jersey I I mean J Moore was a lot
handsome then I'm no I'm know J Moore
but just that feeling that he was a
standup gave me a you know I still
remember coming here and being Miker and
his name he was there was like little uh
newspaper advertisements everywhere with
his name him Bill
Bellamy uh you know I forget who else
then but Felicia Michaels I remember
Nick depalo when I came in 93 those guys
were all Dave Chappelle had just done
Robin Hood Men and tights you know there
was just so many people look at that
Chappelle had that was 31 [__] years
ago
and he's still doing he's still killing
it so Chappelle did a movie then which
at the time you didn't think nothing of
it now when you look at his movie
career it started with that movie well
that one and the stoner one the one
baked Half Baked you know but and Robin
Hood Men and tights yeah it was that's
interesting that like is that how like
they get in is they get they get popular
with the movie and then they can run
with stand
up I've always believed that a lot of
people
don't I think it gives people a
different
look do you think podcasting is is
similar to that
now um I think podcasting is
bigger because you get to know who the
[__] I am you get to know my life what I
went through whether I choose to say it
and you know if I don't choose to can
you imagine like all right let's say
somebody from
Yellowstone okay okay let's talk about
Beth you ever watch yellow Beth I've
watched a couple Clips I know who Beth
is Beth is the best character on
TV but wow bam let's say uh Beth did a
podcast every week she's Australian
right
her yeah so let's say be does a podcast
like I just saw be in a movie with
Denzel he plays the pilot and the pilot
the airline over flight she plays like a
[__] chick that's smoking heroin [__]
oh I didn't know that she just didn't
pop up and get Yellowstone right she did
30 appearances maybe two or three of
them you
caught and that's why like I I don't
know I'm trying to figure out how to do
it
like what am I trying to say
here there's got to be some type of
pages to show people where it all comes
together you know it's like what I I
hate right now what's going on with
comedians people think these Comics just
came out of an apartment when day and
started cracking jokes they discredit
the 20 years before
that you
know I remember opening for Louis CK in
94 or
95 in
Seattle I think Josh Wolf was there with
us are you [__] kidding
me
right and that was a big room then that
was the room in Seattle at the time but
it wasn't a theater it wasn't there was
an improv there it wasn't an a room they
shut it down but I always want people to
know it's a long time and it's not one
thing it's going to be a bunch of little
things and then they all come together
one day some of the best advice one day
I got from executive producer long his
yard he goes this movie didn't shine for
you as as much as you anticipated it but
don't worry about it 10 years from now
this movie is going to
change you and people's eyes because
it's going to connect
you with other roles and other projects
and then people go oh okay I saw him in
an episode of
co-case and that was 2003 I saw him in
taxi and that was 2004 I saw him in
Spider-Man and that was 2002 people
start connecting all that I saw him in
Grudge Match in 2013 I walked out of the
movie theater I saw you know like all I
I saw him in The Sopranos that one I I
was happy he got shot you know people
will tell you and it's pretty
interesting it's very interesting and
the same thing with standup that's why I
told you to do that thing every every 90
days because I want people to document
it that's some it's completely different
than why I thought I told you I told you
to show and write it all it becomes
people acquainted with you now as a
feature act
right you got your own world it's a
YouTube page it don't cost you nothing
if you want people to shop on there they
could buy sneakers on there they could
buy the juice sneakers you were on stage
and all that stuff you know [__] it it's
really a great world and you learn a lot
yeah and one day that knowledge all
comes
together it's I'm I'm looking forward to
that happening but it's also
like it's it's I I I'm nowhere near
quitting up quitting at all
um but it it definitely it stings more
than I'd like to admit it does when like
either a set doesn't go well or if a
club doesn't like me or
I take it personal expect them not to
like you
Lee make believe they're all [__]
German expect
them okay that makes your life
easier expect them not to you expect for
you to walk in and go hi I open up for
Josh and jod Diaz I'm here to report for
Duty and they're like that's great
here's the keys to the condo take a hike
right you know until you become back
valuable to them yeah until one day they
went in the middle of a football game
they see you jumping down up and down a
commercial next
to the the quarterback in Kansas City
yeah Patrick mahom they [__] look at
the TV and go oh [__] I just had that
little [__] at my club last
month now next time you come you're
gonna even though you're not a movie
star and even though you're still a
feature he's going to treat you
differently
how does that make you feel about people
like if they just start treating you
differently when you start like when
when you can help them because now they
see the effort in you now they go
oh if he booked one he could book two
right and if he booked two he could book
three and something really big and here
I am being a [__] to him as a club
manager or as an
agent or as an employee at a club
because now you
become an asset you are a potential this
guy has potential of being in a TV show
as a matter of fact the guy that from
Kirby enthusiasm is taking them on the
road there's little things that people
see and that's why it's it's not their
fault if they don't like you it's the
way that they were
programmed they're not there to hate you
they're there to like you
you know and there's two ways you
could [__] make him laugh and be a
[__] or make him laugh and be a
gentleman right and that's I always TR I
I feel like I'm always polite to
everyone but like when you're looking
back and i' I've heard you talk about it
a little bit but looking back at the for
the people who did help you out when you
couldn't help them do you feel like do
you feel different towards them than you
do against like you know people who come
along later what do you mean like the
first guy like the guys who would bring
you out in Denver or like the guy or you
know have a club started headlining you
when you weren't selling tickets like do
you look back do you look at those
people and like would you do more for
them or like do they mean more to you
than it does for someone who absolutely
there's a guy in Houston that used to
headline me when nobody was even
thinking about it and I remember the
first room I sold out was
Houston like over the Christmas holiday
I sold out one of the shows and the rest
of the shows I wasn't doing
bad and he saw it I didn't see it and I
remember trying to get an
agent a booking agent and if you're not
selling tickets again there's not much a
booking agent could do for you if he
puts you in 10 clubs and you're getting
a 100 a show we got a problem we got to
start from scratch now
thank God because of the podcast and the
Rogan and the movies everything was
falling into place so I went from going
to a club for a weekend first time I
went out as a headliner was Columbus I
ate a bag of dicks they didn't bring me
back for a year and a half and then I
found out they were closed and stuff but
how bad do you think I felt about that
yeah I went selling I went from selling
one night a week for a year I would come
to nyak and do Thursday night sell it
out everybody or then I come back the
next year or two years later and I do
Wednesday and Thursday and sell it out
then I come back two years later and now
I was selling out Wednesday two shows
and Thursday two shows which meant I
could sell out a
weekend right so if I wouldn't have done
that I kept growing I was very
fortunate and the show that made the
statement was me and Ari in the house
Blues in
Chicago really we sold it out and
everybody got a memo they sold at the
House of Blues and everything
changed it's all different
steps when was that you remember I still
remember selling out a show at Ari and
buffalo at a theater like 300 tickets
where we got the Fidel Castro t-shirts
and [__] yeah I remember that one it all
had to start somewhere that was
over you know 15 years ago I had to
be you know so it was all
patience you know that's why when most
comics and then they trick you then
there's people who trick you they'll how
like yesterday the line all week was
four on Baltimore and then they did an
old school trick they raised the line on
you and now it makes you think what's
going on [__] it if they rais the line
they tried to switch all the money to
Baltimore you saw the
result sometimes I I'll do a fake I want
you to look at the steps and how they do
it you do a couple things and all a
sudden they blast you on a theater tour
for
89.95 people want to know why you're
doing theaters and why you charging
$89.95 they think you're going to
see the the [__] beach [__] part
and half and then you you just go it's
another standup comic there's a lot of
marketing tactics that they use and they
get you with them every five or six
years they just trick
you it's the same thing as a marketing
scam but
that's like I I I did a lot of thinking
since last night about this and
like something that I've always like I I
guess admired about you is like how you
would tell me little things but you
would say even before I started standup
like with like agents or managers like
you have to tell them like you have to
say like saying no is hard for me like
saying
no a lot of things in life is hard for
me but this is all new to you this is
all new to
you reason why I like that you're doing
this is because when you get to that
level they can't sell you on this you've
already done the
paperwork this is why I always stick up
for Brendan Brendan didn't have
this Brendan didn't have these six years
seven years that you're experiencing
right now right went from behind a a
[__] dashboard and a computer room to
being a co-host of a podcast you learned
the numbers you
learned when he got into it and I'm not
saying nothing bad about Brendan I love
Brendan to
death he never had this and this is the
period that you want if you're going to
be a comedian a podcaster a [__]
actor which is what we ultimately are at
the end we do it all but I always felt
this period was special to me and most
Comics will tell you because that
prepared you for bigger things without
this period in
comedy two things are going to
happen either you're going to get
demolished early on or you get
demolished you pick up your
bags you go back to but nuts and bolts
and you do it the right
way and next week's podcast we'll talk
about when that happened in Our Moment
of of Comedy you know R came
on and then uh Tim Allen came on and
they were both hits so the
networks got really cool and they said
well let's put on uh a couple other
comedians develop shows with them these
shows got developed and they worked but
because of ratings and [__] like that
the shows didn't work
out and I know three Comics personally
that you know Hey listen when your show
gets
cancelled you can't I can't imagine that
feeling to get that call when you've
gotten out of that realm of standup
comedy Now on your terms now you got to
go in there with your with your tail
between your legs
right and these guys ended up being
three of the best Comics that we have
today Greg Geraldo being one of them
Margaret Cho being the other one and our
great friend Tom you
know no the other guy Tom the crazy guy
rhs didn't Bill bur get a shows cancel
too who Bill Burr yeah early on 98 99 97
an Allstar show that was supposed to
work everybody was a star can you
imagine that if I tell you Hey listen
the guy from Modern Family the guy from
Sons of Anarchy all these stars are GNA
do a network and they want you to do a
recurring role you're like M buy the
house 150 episodes with these [__]
losers and next thing you know the show
gets canceled after 20 episodes because
the ratings are shitty that's a complete
different [__] ego buster but hey
what do you got this week [__]
this week uh the Third on Saturday I'll
be featuring at the dojo 900 pm on
Saturday and then if you're in the city
on thday dojo Scotch Plains or Morris
Plains Morris Plains the comedy Dojo at
tiffs if you if you if you don't if you
Google the dojo you might not find it
but it's at tiffs Andre Kim is the
headliner great guy I'm very excited for
it um and then Thursday and Friday I'll
be at a couple different places in the
city look at my social media all right
there you go hopefully I'll see you
Saturday night after tips
oh I'm pumped yeah that' be great to see
show for you and [__] you get all
nervous and
start stuttering and [__] like this
[__] simoc
cast you should host and [__] just
blow me out of the water no I'm not
hosting I I can't do that to anybody but
hey I love you have a great week I'm
gonna do two sets this week so next time
I see you I'll have two reports for you
[__] I can't wait to hear about it
all right have a great week I love you
guys stay black and uh now for a word
for my [__] sponsor
[Music]
Jack the checkin is brought to you by my
people on it listen you want to start
the year off on a good foot start it off
healthy with a little Alpha Brain and
get that [__] coconut on fire go to
hit.com right now go through see what
they have what works for you the shroom
Tech listen tremendous it don't work on
me no more because my lungs are shot the
bong hits have destroyed it but the
[__] Alpha Brain is still kicking
that's why I'm kicking today I'm on my
[__] cycle I got another two weeks
left and then I'll be reciting [__]
poetry and nii and whatever you [__]
guys bought but anyway go to honor.com
pressing codee coco or Joey and get 10%
off your first order all right